30 years since the black album was put
out what song are you going to do to uh
just celebrate the album stamper true
true anything you want to say about this
song before you perform it i know you've
done it a bunch of times it speaks for
itself and tuning it down just this is a
fun song to play this is the do you want
heavy song what does that mean when you
say tuning it down it was a big deal for
you guys you had never tuned down before
we're not guitar players what does that
mean you're taking the low string and
turning it down in pitch so it gets
lower and heavier we just took
everything down it's like well if one
string's good let's take them all down
that's what we did whose idea was that
to take all the strings down uh probably
the guy tuning our guitars oh really
probably a mistake
probably a great mistake yeah let's
celebrate the album with uh this
performance here's the boys in metallica
uh sad but true great song
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm forever
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
have your here
true
[Music]
[Music]
you're the winner
[Music]
i'm your dream
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh it's so sad true
[Music]
three four one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
love your dreams
[Music]
true
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm your hate i'm your hero
i'm
[Music]
when you can't feel
[Music]
is
[Music]
trump
[Music]
you still have it boys